TV icon dr. Phil comes to youtube star
Logan Paul's defense after Paul's major
backlash for posting a controversial
video let's not bury this young man over
one bad decision
[Music]
dr. Phil's show has been on for 16
successful seasons creating some
breakout stars of its own and he has
some of his signature advice for 22 year
old Logan Paul he posts this video
apparently of an actual body of someone
who had committed suicide in Japan and
he first wrote an apology then gave an
apology video but people are still
calling for him to be removed from
YouTube what do you think he should do
from here
well first off let me say I thought that
what went up on the video and what was
shown was tasteless it was atrocious it
was something that just should not have
been done but let's call timeout here
this is a 22 year old young man and this
is one thing one time one bad decision
let's not judge this young man's whole
life his whole body of work everything
that he's done over one bad decision and
it was a terrible decision it was a
terrible thing to put on the internet
kids see that it's it's inexcusable to
do that but that doesn't mean he's a
horrible person knowing that people do
go on your show and then maybe do go
viral and kind of explode do you give
them any advice afterwards you know
saying being on my show is gonna
skyrocket you and here's how you should
handle this you know I think that when
you vault people in to the public eye we
do talk to them about it we talked to
about it before they ever come on the
show we talked to them about you know
are you in a position to be a teaching
tool but it's not for everybody and and
you know we'll there are a lot of people
that we don't put on the show because we
think that's not the forum for them it's
not the place to them to be and how do
you think about that and are you
prepared to deal with the conversation
it will follow after that
[Music]
you